pour le moment on va passer aux invités
du soir et de plus en plus souvent on
raconte des histoires et on se dit que
on devient fou cette histoire est l'une
d'entre elles à Nant en mai dernier un
policier a été traîné sur une vingtaine
de mètres par un jeune homme de 17 ans
au volant d'une voiture volée et sans
permis de conduire le policier qui a
subi d'importantes blessures à
aujourd'hui de très grandes séquel le
jeune homme par contre a été condamné
écoutez bien à 35 he de travaux
d'intérêt général dans un instant Reda
bellage qui connaît le policier en
question sera avec nous il va tout nous
raconter sur cette histoire vous allez
voir qui incro elle est incroyable
l'histoire parce que c'est elle est
folle et euh 35 euh regardez c'est parti
c'est une rue pavillonnaire aux allures
tranquilles situées en plein cœur des
quartiers Nord deante alors qu'il
s'apprête à contrôler le véhicule le
policier de 38 ans est percuté
violemment par la Renault Mégane le
conducteur a redémarré euh bousculant
euh le fonctionnaire il a été entraîné
sur plus de 20 m ce qui lui a occasionné
un traumatisme crânien et des blessures
euh importantes une bouteille d'eau
merci euh R blage d'être avec nous merci
jean-messia d'être là parce qu'on va
parler d'un autre dossier dans dans un
instant avec l'affaire Naël Reda Béage
est-ce que racontez-nous et racontez à
nos téléspectateurs ce qui s'est passé
pour se policier parce que c'est
complètement fou les collègues ont ont
repéré le véhicule ont voulu tout
simplement procès de contrôle parce qu'
le jeune en question roulait très
bizarrement et au moment où l'individu a
vu les collègues en face de lui il est
sorti de son stationnement il a accroché
notre notre collègue victime il l'a
traîné sur plusieurs
MRE donc le policier a été sérieusement
blessé hein oui sérieusement blessé il a
eu un traumatisme craninien important un
blackout complet à un moment il a eu un
blackout complet en fait il se rappelle
juste d'avoir demandé à l'individu de
couper le couper le moteur et ensuite il
il se souvient d'avoir été traîné sur
quelques mètres il a senti des
fourmimens au niveau du ventre par
rapport à la par rapport à la vitesse
ensuite il se rappelle justeê s'être
réveillé dans le camion des des sapeurs
pompiers euh comment on a pu avoir la
version que de de ce qui s'est
réellement passé est-ce que les les la
justice a eu a eu la version euh oui
dans tout comme toute enquête en
fait les faits sont passés au mois de
mai euh le jugement a eu lieu hier et en
fait le le le résultat en fait le
collègue l'a l'a très très très mal vécu
après si vous avez 2 minutes je peux
vous parce que je l'ai eu au téléphone
en fait et il osait pas venir s'adresser
euh c'est ça public et au chroniqueurs
parce que c'est commême on pense fort à
lui et à sa famille d'ailleurs à sa
femme également voilà je vais vous lire
un petit truc qui m'a envoyé comme ça
comme ça c'est fait alors depuis mon
accident du 2 mai j'ai des séqueles
physiques et surtout psychologiques je
suis resté inconscient presque une
minute au sol mes collègues m'ont cru
mort avec le sang qui culait abondamment
de ma tête un récent IRM a mis en
évidence que mon cerveau avait subi un
traumatisme très important des cellules
de mon cerveau en surface sont dites
mortes le plus dur étant le blackout que
j'ai eu donc je me suis sou je me
souviens de rien mis à part quelques
brides demander au conducteur de couper
le contact puis me voir accrocher au
montant de la portière avec des
fourmimements au ventre dû à la vitesse
de la voiture puis plus rien grâce au
témoignage des riverins et au feeling
des des collègue
d'Orveau que l'individu de 17 ans était
identifié je reste choqué par cet
accident qui aurait pu me coûter la vie
cela me reste en tête et affecte ma vie
personnelle d'ailleurs mes collègues ma
famille le sont tout autant je m'estime
heureux de pouvoir en témoigner
aujourd'hui sur votre plateau et j'ai
été énormément touché par le sort du
collègue de l'affaire naë puisque la
situation était similaire à la mienne
sachez aujourd'hui que je me sens je ne
me sens pas protégé ni ni pris en compte
par la justice compte tenu de la
sentence prononcée au tribunal pour
mineur pendant toute l'audience j'ai eu
l'impression d'avoir été victime d'un
fait beaucoup moins grave l'acte du
jeûne était minimisé ainsi que mes
séquels et mon traumatisme cela
m'inquiète pour la continuité de ma
carrière et de celle de mes collègues
policiers et notre investissement dans
le métier nous tous confrontés à une
violence en constante augment ainsi que
qu'au message envoyé au délinquants avec
ce type de réponse pénale bravo lui
bravo à lui très très fort cette il
paraît vraiment je pense qu'il nous
regarde et je pense fort à lui en tout
cas et je je je suis avec lui à fond
avec lui et sa famille à fond à fond à
fond et je peux vous dire que j'imagine
ce qu'il a dû ressentir quand on a dit
que ce jeune avoir 35 heures de travaux
d'int théorie générale il paraît qu'il a
quitté la salle avant même la la fin oui
il a pas supporté il a pas supportter la
façon dont il a vécu le traitement
judiciaire de l'affaire et je pense que
tous les
policiers sont touchés par cette cette
affaire parce que malheureusement on est
souvent confronté à ce type de choses
mais quand vous essayez de faire votre
travail de flic votre but c'est de
protéger tous les citoyens et là vous
avez l'impression de pas être protégé
tout simplement par par la justice vous
vous n'êtes pas protégé en fait vous et
il paraît que le juge ne voulait pas
couper la dynamique de réinsertion
jeomme g absolument c'estàdire que c'est
surréaliste alors il y avait les
réquisitions un an avec surcis et puis
le juge dit je veux pas entraver la
démarche de réinsertion du prévenu qui
était déscolarisé au moment des fait qui
a repris l'école et puis qui a changé de
comportement avec ses parents ses
proches donc 35 he non mais le le la
décision est abérrante c'est fou quoi le
policier il a des séquelles
irréversibles il a failli mourir le
jeune ne s'est pas arrêté c'est
totalement délirant alors le parquet a
fait appel on verra mais c'est
inadmissible inadmissible donc un
processus de réinsertion c'est de voler
une voiture à 17 ans et traîner un flic
sur 20 m là il était en processus de
réinsertion le
gar a
reprisécole voilà il prend 35 he donc le
message envoyé c'est on peut traîner un
F pendant que ce que je suis en train de
me demander raeda on va pas se mentir il
savait très bien queil fallait qu'il se
tienne à carou et que peut-être qu'il
joue un jeu aussioc lui donner des
conseils c'est ça qui tu bouges pas une
oreille et tout se passera bien et
peut-être qu'on va dire que tu es dans
un dans dans dans dans un mode de
réinceron qui est très efficace un
processus qui est très efficace c'est
c'est du c'est du bullshit excusez-moi
de vous dire ça oui on a eu le cas aussi
si je peux me permettre cy lors de la
manifestation des j'aime pas dire le mot
mais contre les violences policières on
avait V eu des images qui étaient très
choquantes où on a défoncé un véhicule
de police avec des vé des collègues à
bord un collègue a sorti son arme à mon
sens il a sauvé la vie des collègues qui
étaient dans le véhicule la plupart des
individus mis en cause qui étaient des
black block qui étaient mineurs sauf un
qui était majeur il a été déféré j'ai
été au jugement la juge a dit ah
d'accord vous faites je vais pas mett
donner la marque de enfin la
restauration rapide vous êtes en stage
donc je vous laisse le temps de voir
comment on se revoit le 2 novembre vous
m'envoyez votre attestation de stage et
de formation le jugement a eu lieu enfin
devait avoir lieu le 2 novembre et là on
l'a décalé parce que l'avocat était
absent au mois de septembre donc ça veut
dire qu'on aurait pu excusez-moi de dire
le mot mais on aurait pu tuer des
policiers pendant une manifestation des
policiers qui essayent de faire leur
travail
et la réponse elle est là c'estàdire que
aujourd'hui le gars est
dehors juste un mot un mot Jean Messia
juste c'est personne n té raison on va
revenir sur la fernaë dans un instant
parce que le policier à l'origine du tir
mortel remis en liberté on va vous
expliquer tout ça juste sur Messia sur
ce qu'on vient de dire là sur cette
affaire vous dites quoi bah je pense que
la justice le son laxisme est
responsable de l'état d'ensauvagement de
la société là est en train de commenter
une affaire à l'instant mais une fois
que ce jeune qui a manqué de tuer un
policier n'est COP que de 35 heures de
de travaux d'intérêt général
c'est-à-dire de rien B oui de rien
l'étape d'après c'est quoi est-ce que la
justice on va en parler tout à l'heure
n'est pas en train de fabriquer n'a pas
déjà fabriqué des hordes de de futur
Naël justement parce que la justice à
aucun moment ne met un cran d'arrêt à
ceux qui ne respectent rien et qui
ilobéisse à rien donc donc si vous
voulez le maillon faible de notre de
notre pays ce qui explique le cafarnaum
finalement dans lequel nous vivons et
que les flics se prennent en plein
visage dans les rues c'est qu'à aucun
moment la justice ne ne ne ne n'est
capable de de sanctionner suffisamment
durement pour casser les dynamiques
délinquantes et criminelles des jeunes
si chaque jeunes était seulement
condamné au bout du premier acte à
seulement même 3 semaines de prison
peut-être que les choses seraient un peu
mieux par la suite alors